تم نقل قاعدتي من تل أبيب إلى
الجنوب في عام 2002، وطُلب مني
إرسال طائرات لتزويد الطائرات بالوقود التي كانت
متجهة إلى غزة لقصف غزة، في ذلك
الوقت لم تكن لدي اللغة اللازمة
لفهم ما يحدث بالضبط ولكن
كما كنا  عندما عدت إلى القاعدة تعرضت
لنوبة الهلع الأولى ولم أتمكن من دخول
القاعدة وفي اليوم التالي كان علي أن آتي
وأمثل للمحاكمة وتم إبعادي عن
القاعدة لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع وفي تلك
الأسابيع الثلاثة أدركت أنه يجب علي
مغادرة القاعدة
الجيش وهذا ما أعرفه في تلك اللحظة
جعلني أرغب في إنهاء حياتي لأنه
كان مخالفًا لكل ما
تعلمته وهذا بدأ عملية
سأظل فيها لبقية
حياتي وهي التراجع عن هذا
التلقين و  إن غسيل الدماغ
والطريقة التي تم بها دمج الهوية الإسرائيلية
مع الهوية الصهيونية،
رسالتي هي قبل كل شيء لكل من
يستطيع أن يجد قلبه
ويحرر نفسه من هذه الهوية
التي نسميها هوية إسرائيلية
وليس هناك حاجة لذلك.  أي واحد منا
يخدم في جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي، لا ينبغي لجيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي أن
يوجد، لا ينبغي لدولة إسرائيل أن
توجد، يمكننا أن نكون أحرارًا بدونها، يمكننا أن
يكون لدينا اتصال حقيقي بقلوبنا
بدون تلك
الهوية